[Music]
hi my name is gloria calderon khaled i
am the executive producer creator and
showrunner of with love
and my mantra is if you can't see it be
it so someone else can see it and that
really comes from my time in hollywood
where when i was coming up there were
not a lot of women and definitely not a
lot of latina women who were doing what
i wanted to do and so i thought well if
i don't have one role model i will
compile many and then if i make it then
hopefully i can be a role model to
someone else so that's kind of how it
all came about and now there's so many
more
women in hollywood that are doing this
so many women of color that are creating
their own shows and it's a really
exciting time
[Music]
yes and no i knew i wanted to be a
storyteller but i didn't know what that
looked like because i didn't know
writing was even a job directing was
even a job i knew acting because that
was what you see on the screen
so when i first came to los angeles i
thought oh i want to be an actor and
then the more i got into the industry
the more i was frustrated by the lack of
roles for women
and i decided to start writing my own
and then as i started writing i found a
new joy and a new way to express myself
and then when i got on sets i saw what
the director was doing and i thought oh
that seems really interesting too so i
started directing and now
directing writing producing and acting
are really what i do and it kind of
blows my mind that i get to do all of
that it's awesome
[Music]
i think the thing to know about the
industry is that it takes time
especially if you don't know anyone
there i didn't know anyone my parents
knew nothing about hollywood i grew up
in portland oregon uh so it was all a
mystery to me
and i think that a lot of people come to
hollywood and they're like i'm gonna
give it six months
and you gotta you gotta be committed to
this like you would be committed to
becoming a lawyer and putting in a
decade or being a doctor and putting in
a decade this takes a decade in my case
decades i started in hollywood when i
was 22 and now i'm 46 and i have the
life of my dreams now but it took this
long and that's okay
so i think this next generation is so
exciting because there's so much talent
so much energy but give yourself the
grace of time in that time you're gonna
learn so much and it's okay you don't
have to be defined by what your job is
right now the journey is just as
important as the destination
[Music]
oh gosh i would like my legacy to be
creating spaces for people that have not
traditionally got to be in those spaces
i think that there's a really exciting
thing happening in television right now
where
people who haven't always had the story
centered on them are starting to be the
face of their own show those are the
shows i'm most interested in right now
are seeing a different point of view
a different person from a different
culture sharing their story and what
their journey is and i think the more we
create space for that the more it unites
us and allows us to really see
how much like we are and in these very
divided times those are the stories that
make me feel connection so i hope my
legacy would be that i contributed to
that that i contributed to the building
of bridges with my work
i hope my mantra has inspired you today
and that you know that every part of
this journey is an amazing part
[Music]